the jurogan experience new york is fine
man it's not fun it's fine i'm there
it's doomed
it's beautiful even the governor's
sexually groping people that's that's
even italian bro that is being italian
joe you're disrespecting culture excuse
me it's the greatest excuse ever amazing
excuse me i'm not a pervert i'm italian
i'm napoludon
this is this is our culture
joe this is our culture did you see kyle
dunnigan's taking no what are you doing
oh my god kyle duncan he's got great
stuff shout out to kyle man shout out to
cal dunnigan and kirk yeah yeah yeah
having them both come on together oh god
bless they have
one of the best shows that's ever
existed yeah first of all they're doing
they do that biden sitcom okay have you
seen that uh the fresh present
oh my god it's [ __ ] amazing because
it's all face swaps yeah yeah so he's
got biden and the fake swaps yeah and
now he's got
he's fighting
yeah
it's [ __ ] amazing but yeah it's
the the new one that he did with cuomo
give me some volume he's got this thing
it's the andrew cuomo rocket chart show
like here
oh i can work my way into your hearts
with my personal stories an informative
channel i did see this it's the governor
andrew cuomo rocking chat shop
quick story
when i was a boy i would watch howdy
doody one day i received a gift it was a
howdy doody doll it was my favorite toy
to play with
until the day i found something more fun
to play with my penis
sit back relax and take me in i'll
entertain and touch you that's a real
win-win it's the governor's andrew cuomo
rock and chalk show
here he talks about trucks
welcome to the show
we'll be getting to the controversy and
my imminent arrest in a minute
for some housekeeping
i have decided to ditch mitch
and go with a young hip sidekick
the king of staten island pete davidson
pete what's happening
uh
nothing i guess
fascinating
okay i have been accused of touching
women's privates
not true
i'm italian
we talk with our hands
and all that my hands were saying was
what time is it and sometimes when you
hear your family
it makes sense
yeah family
love it
you gotta admit that's an all-time
excuse though
it's a ridiculous thing in the video
that you that he put up did you see the
video where he was like
oh cuomo one i think it was like at the
press conference
he put up this video of him like
touching all the people he goes i've
touched men i and there's a picture of
him kissing a guy i've touched women
i've touched powerful people he's
holding bill clinton's face as he's like
kissing him on the cheek and it was like
a really it was interesting defense
because at the start i'm like can i see
that can i see the video you know what
i'm talking about touch everyone cuomo
shows gallery of him kissing men women
yeah lgbtq he was snitching on himself
he's like he's like you think i touch
people of course i touch and he just put
all
the different people that he's touched
but it looked kind of innocent look
let's see this let me give you some
volume
he's narrating
oh my god
oh you got three seconds two one ants
here we go
raised against me questions
that have sought to unfairly
characterize and weaponize everyday
interactions that i've had with any
number of new yorkers
the new york times
published a front page picture of me
touching a woman's face at a wedding
and then kissing her on the
cheek that is not front page news
i've been making the same gesture in
public
all my life
i actually learned it
from my mother that's her fault
i learned how to be a pervert from my
mom
it's a long line of perverts nothing
more
indeed there are hundreds if not
thousands of photos of me using the
exact same gesture
i do it with everyone
black and white
young
and old
straight in lgbtq
powerful people look at this look at
this clinton one night
after the event
the woman told the press that she took
offense at the gesture
and for that i apologize
another woman stated that i kissed her
on the forehead
let me hear that part
miss party
and that i said ciao bella
now i don't remember doing it
but i'm sure that i did
i do kiss people on the forehead
i do kiss people on the cheek
i do kiss people on the hand
i do embrace people
i do hug people
men and women
i do on occasion say
ciao bella
on occasion
i do slip
and say sweetheart people
i do tell jokes
some better than others
i am the same person in public
as i am in private
you have seen me do it on tv through all
my briefings and for 40 years before
that i try to put people at ease
i try to make them smile i try to
connect with them
and i try to show my appreciation and my
friendship
i now understand that there are
generational
or cultural perspectives
that frankly i hadn't fully appreciated
and i have learned from this
now the state already has
an advanced sexual harassment training
program for all employees including me
but i want new york state government to
be a model of office behavior
and i brought in an expert okay
so this is all before he resigned yes
that was the last ditch effort like we
were supposed to see that and be like
you're okay and but it's more than that
that he's accused of the accusations are
crazy right the accusations he was
trying to like finger girls right yeah
the act like that like ciao bella did
someone get upset at that
maybe
i don't i think that's a little bit
crazy i mean he is like an older italian
guy so there's going to be a certain why
is that it means hello beautiful yeah
why is that effect
or goodbye beautiful yeah that's right
yeah yeah yeah so you're italian yeah
yeah i mean how do you like
resist
touching yeah like how does that
italians not come out like i don't know
when you're around pitch i have a little
bit of irish in me oh that's what it can
do
you just go like this he's like five
percent standoff in me
i don't know but yeah he's being an old
guy he's [ __ ] what is he 70 years old
i don't want to win just that
i think there's some serious [ __ ] yeah
and you know maybe he's trying to hit on
girl he's trying to get his dick wet a
little bit do you know the whole story
with the lady who is she's the attorney
general right the one who prosecuted
james
yeah yeah do you know she was in another
party and he made her denounce her party
in order to come over to work for him
and then she immediately went after him
whoa
uh is that yeah yeah
it's wow so he's got like a history of
making women do things they don't want
to do well i don't know if he made it
you know i think it's a political thing
you probably wouldn't do it too bus and
balls but yeah it's uh
it's um yeah it's just so interesting i
don't know because you see that you're
like yeah this is how old people were
like old people were way more tactile
yeah at least like mediterranean folks
yeah they were very touchy that's fine
and i don't think that's and i think
that's a lot of like the biden thing
like you know like the biden sniffing
kids [ __ ] i don't like that
right you wouldn't let him sniff your
kid that bothers me i let them sniff my
kids really a hundred that's how many
kids
once you have kids you're like why are
you sniffing my kid
your father instincts would kick in
let me think
plus i i don't think you'd remember if
it's a kid or not i think you'd be
confused just in the moment he's like
this is a smaller person that's it yeah
i just sniffing midgets dude that's
that's one of my favorite pastimes dude
i'm a [ __ ] sniffer dude i if i see a
[ __ ] i gotta smell them dude they
smell so delicious
i just don't think like i think that
thing is is way bigger a deal than it
needs to be sniffing yeah like the
cognitive ability is the thing that
scares me not sniffing kids right just
keep the kids away from them i think the
sniffing kids in public is part of the
cognitive decline like he doesn't
recognize that people don't like that
but you don't think it's just him being
two hundred look at him look at all
these kids that one on the side is
[ __ ] up at the bottom right
i mean it looks like he's like pulling
yeah they're all [ __ ] up yeah that one
she's really uncomfortable away from
them yeah they're distorting their
facial expressions yeah that's very
strong but why would they smell like
that like why would they come in
smelling like that joe
why why would they wear perfume that
smells so good why would they do that
they want to be sniffed am i a victim
blamer maybe holy [ __ ] dude maybe but
just for sniffing it's like
it's the worst i mean if if that's the
worst thing that happens to you you get
sniffed yeah like you can get over a
sniff you know it should and i think
it's an older person thing i think the
cuomo stuff that was messed up is
probably he was trying to finger these
girls or grabbing titties or just being
a real like scumbag and um
i'm just not surprised like anybody like
that wants to be in a position of power
yeah uses their power shitty
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify